and now to some breaking news from
Washington DC with the State Department
has just announced that it's designating
Muhammad Ali oughtta be that's the
former Consul General of Saudi Arabia in
Istanbul
he's accused of gross human rights
violations in the murder case of Saudi
dissident journalists Jamal [ __ ] let's
bring in patty Callahan she's joining us
live from Washington DC so what does
this mean exactly patty and how serious
is it to tell you the truth not a whole
lot basically it means that this
gentleman and his family can no longer
be allowed into the United States now as
you mentioned Mohammed allow Toby
he was already sanctioned because of the
murder of democracy Shoji along with
more than a dozen others and those were
the much more serious sanctions those
could have included an asset freeze but
so why now why are they doing this well
the State Department release that just
came out said this is international
human rights day so they picked two
people he is one of them so the
sanctions against him not all that
significant but what could be seen as
significant is across the globe all of
the people that the US could have chosen
they chose him and it does send a
message and they a lot and there's
basically saying that they are still
calling for Saudi Arabia to conduct a
fair a transparent trial of those
involved this is not a story that people
have been talking about in the US the
keshavjee murder has really disappeared
from the headlines this has the
potential to bring it back that's
somewhat unusual because this is the
Trump administration they've gone to
great lengths to try and really tamp
down this story so this is sending a
message that the US State Department
Elise is still taking this seriously
patty someone for that patty Cao hain
with the latest live in Washington DC
thank you